his committees here so we can go ahead
and get going
Connor is in the master's program he is
a graduate of Oregon State University
and is now in our program in addition to
his bioinformatics work he also does
some work with a leash Boudreau and
Annette Totten on a project related to
tella telemedicine at the VA so we'll
let him get started all right well thank
everyone for coming this afternoon the
doctor says I said my name is Connor
Smith I'm a master's student here so
today I'm going to be talking about
differential methylation in the context
of somatic mutations in ml so I'm gonna
start off with some background info real
quick on just AML and DNA methylation
and everything like that so acute
myeloid leukemia is the most common
adult leukemia is the most common I
thought leukemia acute leukemia
there's it in 2018 doesn't expected they
expect over 19,000 new cases and about
ten are over ten thousand deaths due to
ML in 2018 ml is a cancer of the blood
in bone marrow and it's caused by
abnormal growth and differentiation of
thematic politicals
which include the myeloid stem cells and
the myeloid blast these cells are both
precursors to red blood cells platelets
and white blood cells when immature
versions of these cells gain some type
of advantage over healthy cells they
start to grow and replicate out of
control
on average patient undergoing chemo will
incur up just over two on average over
two hundred and eighty thousand dollars
in medical bills and that double more
than doubles - over five hundred
forty-four thousand dollars when
patients undergo stem-cell transplant so
as far as the genetics go AML actually
has been found to have fewer mutate the
genomic mutations and most solid tumors
a study of 200 patients found that an
average of only 13 mutations were found
within genes and with an average of five
being genes recurrently mutated AML a
particular interest of these gene and
this is an overall study of mutations
that were found in different genes of
AML ranked based on how prevalent they
were of interest here are the second and
third ones DNA methylation and chromatin
modifiers we're gonna start by talking
about DNA methylation and move on the
carpod chromatin modifiers afterwards so
healthy na methylation and histone
modification involved with regulating
DNA access and transcription but in
different ways as i said we're going to
first start with DNA methylation and
then move forward to histone
modification afterwards so what is DNA
methylation DNA methylation is the
process by which a methyl group is added
to the city the cytosine site in a CPG
site of DNA this is mediated by DNA
methyltransferase enzymes known as DN m
T's these use a methyl group from a esse
dental adenosylmethionine than its Sam
to methylate the cytosine in general
there are two types of methyl
methylation what we care about for this
when talking about somatic cells and
cancer is de novo methylation which is
specifically mediated by dnmt3a so DNA
methylation it is a reversible process
while dnmt dean empties perform the
methylation
methylation of a cytosine a deceit
gee site.the 1011 translocation enzymes
specifically Tet to responsible for D
methylating idh1 and 2 are also involved
in the processing of required resources
for Tet 2 additionally a woman's tumor 1
which is a transcription factor has been
shown to recruit Tet - 2 method in order
to methylate sites in the tart and the
gene at WT 1 is targeting this cause is
tattooed 2d methylate and nearby sites
and then activate that gene so how does
what is methylation do exactly so
concentrations of CPG sites referred to
as CPG Islands are commonly found within
the promoter regions promoter regions of
normal of genes that are actively
transcribed are primarily unmethylated
allowing normal transcription when these
regions become more methylated
transcription is interrupted or
sometimes it can be stopped entirely but
this effect isn't absolute studies have
found that the relation between DNA
methylation and transcription is not
one-to-one of interest we mentioned di
mentioned dnmt3a earlier which is the
enzyme that methylated see sites has
actually been found that when the
promoter region of one study found that
when the promoter region of dnmt3a is
methylated it actually leads to the same
effect that a mutation within dnmt3a
would cause so that kind of shows how
one of the possible effects in an
interesting case on a global scale hypo
methylation within coding regions leads
to increased transcription including
genes that are normally repressed hyper
methylation means that there's a reduced
number of CPG sites that are methylated
but there still can be methylated CPG
sites there for exam causes of hyper
methylation dnmt3a mutations can lead to
a high permit a hypo methylation
phenotype conversely hyper methylation
within the coding regions will lead to a
reduction of transcription once again
hyper methylation refers to an overall
increase of methylated sites but it
doesn't mean
none of the sites are unmethylated so
what is this matter in cancer and cancer
it's been found that DNA methylation and
specifically differential methylation
can be used as a biomarker differential
methylation is where samples in a group
have markedly higher or lower
methylation levels than expected
and this has been widely studied
differential variability is still being
investigated it's not quite as
established but studies have shown the
potential for both of these factors in
specific genes to predict survival real
sorry predict survival relapse and also
disease progression one study found that
there was an association between high
heterogeneity meaning high variability
of methylation status within a group and
their overall survival in that case it
was their survival was lower so how is
this transcription modified we've
already talked about DNA methylation so
now we're going to talk about the other
group histone modification chromatin
modifiers so as I said before chromatin
modifiers it was number three in the AML
genes in terms of how often it was
mutated so within this context histone
modification will can affect current
transcription more interestingly
transcription outside histone
modification can also affect the DNA
methylation of sites near that histone
during histone modification polycomb
repressive complex - PRC - is involved
in the methylation of histones when a
histone becomes tri methylated dnmt3a
binds to the catalytic domain ezh - and
subsequently methylates a nearby CPG
additionally a SXL one seen here affects
these poly poly cone Group proteins
especially PRC - it's believed that ASX
a1 can both activate and repress these
PSG's so that leads us to our study what
if we talked we from what we've talked
about we know that DNA methylation is a
normal
the central process not specific to AML
and we know that they allow patients
commonly common we have mutations in
these genes so naturally we led to this
question our DNA methylation and
differential methylation and variability
events more common in the genes of AML
and AML patients with somatic mutations
of DNA methylation genes as I said since
ene methylation is just an overall
process why are these so common in these
patients so for our study my firt our
first name is the development of an
annotated integrated data set of AML
patients from T from the Cancer Genome
Atlas TCGA for this we're going to
combine the clinical methylation and
mutation data sets into one data set and
it's going to require a lot of cleaning
and harmonization as well as expensive
annotation or to support studying our
central hypothesis additionally we're
going to be evaluating the outcomes in
TCA jatis so that we can analyze them in
our second name you know our second name
identification of differential DNA
methylation patterns in patients with
mutated DNA methylation enzymes so for
this we're going to be analyzing the
differential methylation and variability
and within the AML genes the cancer
genes and genes not associated with
cancer and our whole purpose behind this
to see is to see whether or not these
events are more common in any of those
subsets of genes additionally we're
going to analyze genome-wide patterns of
differential methylation variation and
at this point once we've analyzed
clinical outcomes we're going to see if
there's any association with these
differential methylation and variation
events with the outcome measures so I'm
going to describe the methods and the
study design the study is based off of
the TCGA data which is cases only so for
this we're going to be first we're going
to be combining these two data the data
is found in two locations primarily
we're going to be getting the somatic
mutation and clinical data from C by
portal which is about it which is 194
subjects and the methylation data from
GBC data portal which is on 40 and user
combined that comes down to 140 subjects
from there we're also going to be doing
an extensive amount of annotation so
that these can be analyzed so real quick
I want to talk about how we measure DNA
methylation this is a picture of the
Illumina 450k methylation array the chip
for that so within each of these twelve
sample wells there's a number
there's over 450,000 sites that have a
that 450,000 probes so when the DNA from
the samples from the different cells of
the sample is fragmented it is in
bisulfite converted meaning that any
unmethylated seep sites will be
converted to uracil which is read as
climbing and then the methylated ones
will be retained as a cytosine so then
they'll bind to the probe and when a
single base extinction happens it will
then send off a color signal red
indicates that the site is unmethylated
and green indicates that the site is
methylated so then this is so as I said
each patient contributes one sample
which contains many cells this is then
repeated across all 12 wells and for
each of those patients it's going to it
has a an overall ratio of methylated to
unmethylated this presents a lot of
issues when it comes to data cleaning
just because of the number of different
factors that can influence it a couple
of those factors we need to account for
is the different colors there's a color
bias inherent with the system with the
data and doing with background noise
there's a number of methods that exist
to deal with this and so that's what
we'll be using to remove the technical
artifacts
additionally the 450k system uses two
types of probes which can do introduce
another additional biases i earlier I
showed a demonstration of the probes
there's actually a little bit more to it
but we showed
just the basic ones for simplicity's
sake we can see here that the different
kind of probes kind of lead to the
separation that needs to be dealt with
so are these as far as the annotation
how are these probes assigned to genes
and genomic features primarily we're
going to be looking for probes that
exist within transcription sites so
first exon second exon everything like
that the promoter sequences and within
enhancer sequences we're going to be
using the encode database for first
assistant with enhancers and additional
methods that help deal with just how
complicated the enhancers can get and
with the chromatin now I we have the
support of the beet beet AML project
which is dealt with these in the past
including my Clooney and Peter reiben
they've dealt so we have plenty of
resources to help to this step so after
in order since I mentioned before this
is a cases only study that means that we
don't have healthy controls so for this
what we are interested is looking at the
different sin methylation between the
samples that have mutations and the ones
that don't so what are the mutations
that we care about these are all the
mutations that were going to be
primarily focusing on these are the
numbers you can see on the right and
indicate how prevalent they are within
the TCGA data set the first one dnmt3a
is i mentioned before is the methylation
enzyme the next group is tattoo idh1 ith
two and wt1
all of these are tattoo idh1 and idh two
are all involved with demethylation and
WT one has that association with
demethylation as well additionally we
have two enzymes that are common that
are involved with histone modification
there are a number of other enzymes that
exist within the PRC - but we're
choosing these because they've been
shown in the past to be involved with
AML and they're calling lastly ones that
I haven't mentioned before our flick 3
and MP
why neither of these are involved with
methylation but they are so prevalent in
the AML dataset that we will need to
account for them they there's a couple
interactions that we know that these
have specifically with teen MT 3a so we
know that we can't just leave them out
but we do need to adjust some during
analysis so as far as far as the data
goes this is a cool occurrence plot
showing how how often these co-occur
together and what our sample groups look
like are ones that we will consider as
our non-mutated samples are going to be
these ones in green which are ones that
only have who have no mutations and any
of these genes have foot 3 mutations or
NPM one this comes to 70 samples the
rest in red are going to be the ones
that are considered a mutated samples
this also comes to 70 so it's split 70
70 when just considering these now that
being said there's a little bit more
complicated with this I previously
mentioned that hyper methylation within
the promoter region of dnmt3a led to a
similar effect downstream on the
methylation because of because of this
were interested in looking at that so
there's an extra little step in here
where we're going to be looking for non
mutated samples that may have hyper
methylation in their promoter or first
exon that could lead to a similar effect
downstream so I've mentioned a lot about
differential methylation and variation
but I just want to touch on it a little
bit more so it's a little more concrete
on the right though starting on the left
you can see an example of differential
methylation this speaks to the
difference in meaning between two groups
it's identified this for use when you're
modeling to determine whether or not
there's a difference between two groups
as for differential variation or
variability this refers to a spread in
the overall methylation status between
samples this is also going to be found
using linear modeling techniques so once
now that we have a better idea of
differential methylation and variation
that brings
to the first part of our aim - or we're
going to be looking at the genes within
the different groups as I mentioned
before the primary catalyst to why we
came to this idea is that DNA
methylation is common in all cells and
not specific to ml but it's very common
in AML patients so we're interested to
see whether or not these mutations occur
more common in any certain type of group
so all of the probes which after
cleaning their ends up to be just under
half so around 200,000 probes will be
grouped and rather annotated by what
type of gene they also which of these
categories they fit into so the AML
genes are going to be based off of a
subset that beat a ml has already
curated cancer genes coming from cosmic
and then genes not associated with
cancer this is a just a visual
representation of the idea behind this
so in each of these groups will have
probes from both mutated and non-mutated
indicated by the plus and minus we're
then going to compare the methylation
between those and from there we'll get a
list of probes that have either that
where we found differential methylation
or differential variation then we're
going to compare how these we're going
to compare how prevalent these are
within these groups and see if there's
any difference
none of these probes will cross between
these different groups we can't do
direct the probe comparison but we can
see how often genes are hyper methylated
hypomethylated anything like that within
these different groups after we do this
addressing our central hypothesis we're
going to then do a genome-wide analysis
that's going to be more of an
exploratory or yeah exploratory so with
that we're going to then continue to do
the methylation analysis across all
probes and look for look for patterns
there the one issue is this is it's
going to bring in a larger set of probes
and so I it's going to incur a multiple
testing penalty
as well on the in our central one we're
going to be focusing on we're going to
be looking at the clinical outcomes that
are associated with differential
methylation differential variation so as
we said before we need to evaluate all
the outcomes that exists in the TCA TCGA
dataset and consider the effects of
co-occurrence and also cited genetics
and then we'll perform that analysis so
as far as limitations for the study goes
it's a relatively small sample size it's
all seventy subjects in each group
additionally there's a large number of
probes as I said before the array has
over 450,000 probes per sample and so
there's a large multiple testing penalty
with this after cleaning there's about
200,000 or just about half probes left
and then from there they'll be further
restricted in our first analysis based
on ones that actually exist within genes
lastly there's a large co-occurrence of
mutations as I showed in that showed in
the figure before I with significant
overlap with that too a lot of these
mutations have different overall effects
mutations in Dene mt3 a usually lead to
a hypo methylation while mutations in
the demethylation genes lead to a hyper
methylation so there's concerns about
how these effects could play with each
other and so that's one of our
limitations and additionally we have
concerns with foot 3 and n PM 1 which we
know are very common in AML and also
interact with other mutations that are
present so our plan for this is to do
sensitivity analysis but we are going to
run into some issues with that due to
sample size as far as our timeline goes
this will be the primary research will
be completed over the summer and in the
fall is when it will be completed thank
you very much and if you have any
questions
[Applause]
[Music]
so the question was what is he'll what
will the overall impact of this really
we're kind of trying to look more into
we've just noticed this pattern and it's
very interesting and so we're trying to
find out more about those see if there's
anything behind it so it's kind of a
kind of a pilot eye that could be
expanded like I said the sample size is
pretty low so I don't expect any
groundbreaking discoveries but that's
immediately going to impact great talk
I'm curious to hear more about how you
plan to incorporate prior knowledge and
calling the somatic mutations for the
chromatin and methylation modification
genes um so the mutations are already
the files that we're getting it's all
publicly available data from TCGA and
specifically with the mutation data
they've already called and had given us
the specific they've given us what it is
is that what you're referring to
or is it oh yeah I was just I mean I'm
basically just asking like you know the
where you called mutations in each of
these genes and how you've decided that
they're true mutation true somatic
mutations okay so at this I think we're
just going to be taking TCGA up there
their word so because we have like I
said this is all publicly available data
mostly highly due to time constraints so
that's as far as we can really dormant
so but if you find that there is no
difference in differential methylation
between two of the groups for example
the cosmic and and the AML genes in that
case I that would lead me to believe
that really it's not a that would tell
me that it's it may just be a fact that
their cancer genes
may be what's causing their leading to
disease from there that's that's one of
the I mean if we find that out it's
still an outcome it's still something
that would be interested to know we know
at least in this study we went to found
that there's a over overabundance of
them within the AML genes but you'd
still be interesting for the fuel okay
thanks
okay thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]